left there
they're asking for an encore all right
here are our overtime questions this is
for you Francis why did Congress fail to
hold social media companies accountable
for their role in the January 6th attack
on the capitol
um it's interesting so uh despite I did
I did a huge amount of testimony for the
January 6th I know you did and I believe
none of it was included in like the
final write-up report like it wasn't one
of the attributable things I think part
of it was that uh the January 6th
committee felt it needed to educate the
public on a very broad set of issues and
that I think they had to pick and choose
on like how many things are we really
going to walk people down that road and
so which was smart which was I mean that
committee was smart yeah I mean didn't
do anything it didn't do it no but I
mean I've seen the interviews with the
Republicans and everything changes
anybody's mind about anything but you
can't blame the committee they put on a
show that was a good show and that was a
smart decision I'm sorry but they had a
lot of fish to fry and that one okay but
I want to be super clear Facebook could
have had on the safety measures that
were available on the day of an election
they could have turned those on on a day
sooner than after 6 pm on January 6th
because they had them all had none of
them on at 6 pm at 6 p.m on January 6th
and they had them all on by 24 hours
later and they all threw Trump off right
Twitter right after January 6. and this
week he got back on he's reformed
it's a miracle he's a completely
different guy now what happened it's
hysterical okay uh Barry given the
attack on the synagogue in Jerusalem
today are we looking at a potential
intifada in Israel God I hope not
um
but you know as Hamas I believe already
called it a heroic operation and
you don't make peace with your friends
obviously but it's very hard to make
peace when your enemy is not actually
trying to fight for territory but is
trying to fight to eliminate you uh
the attack happened earlier today you
know as people were praying it happened
to be International Holocaust
Remembrance Day the day that Auschwitz
was liberated and it turns out that some
80 years later people still want to hunt
Jews down
yeah not just there yeah I mean
anti-Semitism has been on the rise all
around the world I mean there are people
leaving France because they don't feel
comfortable in France I mean you know
places we didn't think this was possible
yeah I think that people don't
um
I came on the show after the attack on
my synagogue in Pittsburgh and I think a
lot of people and there's no reason they
would know this don't realize that you
know for me to walk into a synagogue
even here in La there's there's armed
guards at Jewish Day schools at
synagogues it's just a JCC's it's just a
normal part of life as an American Jew
and that's a very very strange reality
okay
um should Alec Baldwin be facing
involuntary manslaughter charges in the
fatal shooting of the Senate
photographer on the set of his film last
year
no I I mean look I I mean I don't know
Alec Baldwin very well at all he used to
do this show he stopped doing it years
ago so when I'm just setting this up
like I have no personal I have no I'm
not for him or against him I like him as
an actor I don't really know him
but unless you think Alec Baldwin
purposely shot this cinematographer what
the are we talking
you know it's like
yeah
horrible tragedy and then you know there
may be someone to blame whoever whose
job it was to to have that gun there but
I don't think it's the actor's job no
the only well there's two there's two
additional things one he I think he was
a producer on the film it's not the
producer's job either to check the guns
I mean you have to be able to delegate
some things in life no well but the only
thing that he's he said that he didn't
pull the trigger
and the gun can't go I mean I I don't
know enough about this case but he said
he couldn't pull the trigger but how
does a gun go off without pulling the
trigger
that is it that's the one thing that I
was like that's a little odd right he
did say that didn't he yeah what I don't
know I I don't know he's an actor you
know
I mean I just I just guard them on a
judge them on attention but are they
going after him because he is a
celebrity like what is the I just think
we live in a culture where someone
always has to take a blame nobody can
ever just throw up their hands and go oh
my God this is a terrible tragedy you
know Democrats always have to say this
could never happen again no matter how
rare something we have to spend a
zillion dollars so this will never
happen again and Republicans will be
like well now they're going after your
prop guns you know
no one can ever just be reasonable about
anything all right uh what do you make
panel of the way different Democratic
Mayors and governors Lori Lightfoot okay
that's the mayor of Chicago Eric Adams
that's New York
Jared Polis we had him here he's the
governor yeah Governor of Colorado right
have reacted to the immigration crisis
oh I see where you're going with this in
in their Hometown yes all those three
have have said basically so funny
because they either they you know we're
basically saying that the thing that
they're not supposed to say which is
that uh I know we're we're love
immigrants and we're Sanctuary cities
we're Sanctuary City but we can't take
an immigrant
we're we're all full up right now
yeah what do you think about that in the
Democratic side there yeah I mean it's
they're kind of caught in a political
mess you know what did you say about the
immigration issue when you were running
in Ohio against JD Vance I said that we
need to know who's coming in and out of
this country I don't think that's an
unreasonable request right I think
we have unlimited to a degree we have
well I mean you know we are America
because we take people from around the
world as part of our economic engine
that we have so we got to have an adult
conversation about it but even Canada
has restrictions no you can't have
people streaming over the ground or not
know who they are if you don't think
there are right people who are
terrorists or Bad actors coming across
um I think there's a way to do it in a
humanitarian way and then figure out
who's coming in and out use the
technology that we have now which is
enormous and we could we could figure it
out how do you keep the fentanyl out of
the country you have to try to figure
out how to get that out of here
because that's killing tons of people
and then and then if you're here
you know pay a fine pay back taxes pass
a background check and welcome to the
United States it's it's amazing that you
know so many issues that you talk about
if people were just not hateful toward
each other and could could do Grand
Bargains like they used to yeah it's
it's not you said you know there's got
to be something in between the rule
rapists and come one come on right yeah
there is which is why normal people are
right insane with what's going on in the
country because these are solvable
problems all of them the Obesity peace
the technology piece the immigration
it's all solvable yes if you
talk to each other like that it has to
be a part
[Applause]
okay a uh a recent study found that less
than half 49.7 percent of students at
Cambridge University identify it as
heterosexual
that's hysterical because we did it
because I've seen the charge we did a
thing where we projected and then I
think we said in 2054 we will all be gay
because of where it's going and now
apparently Cambridge is saying hold my
appletini
so this is the first study I've ever
seen where or they're just really
open-minded you never know
sorry well the mind is one thing
there was something a little more I mean
the question says is it no longer
politically correct to say you're
straight it's this I mean could we have
changed that much we're now over half
well non-heterosexual someone asked me
the other day if I identified as queer
because I'm gay and I was like
um no because everyone I know that
identifies as queer is just straight and
they're calling themselves that to sound
better is that right so I I think
straight people say they're queer of
course are you kidding me do you know
how many people I know in heterosexual
relationships that identify that
self-identify is queer
okay I thought queer meant gay but if
they're bi like where does that fall on
this Continuum I'm just confused I'm
confused too
yeah
it's like we've known we've known since
the 60s when Kinsey came out with his
first studies that most many people
identify as not purely straight or
purely gay the people will say like oh
you have the right the right person who
knows so like is that what those
Cambridge kids are doing like more of
them are saying I'm bi I'm not I refuse
to being gay or like a fish identify
also I brought this up before ancient
Rome you know they're all Queer uh
self-identified again
they did not make the distinction we do
between the between gay and straight it
was more like cute or not yeah you know
like you know Mark Anthony burning man
yeah I had a wife
what she's like a very Burning Man which
yes is that what goes on and burning man
everything goes out everything goes
I learned so much so much 100 of the
people there identified this show was
like the learning addicts for me
we gotta go thank you very much
everybody
[Applause]